tell me about the fight the fight so
i was supposed to fight john pascal
rematch rematch right
i beat him the first time yes you did
and they they robbed me was supposed to
fight
uh like over a year ago so i waited 18
months for the rematch
i fought on his show to stay busy fight
and um
he tested positive for four different
steroids oh [ __ ] he broke the
record yeah he broke the regular
steroids right yeah all that stuff
we suspected it the first fight we asked
for vital testing they didn't test us
and
and then for the rematch we we begged
them and they they finally agreed to buy
the testing
and see what happened right yeah it was
on that stuff because he was looking
like that for too
[ __ ] long you know even people down
and camp with him
they called us after they're like listen
this guy's juiced to the guild and the
first fight the punishment that he took
in the second half of the fight i mean
he wouldn't have made it so this fight
you know we
i hate to say we knew but we knew listen
why can't they
vacate his title well listen mike that's
what we wanted to do we wanted
to do it no you have to he's here here's
the thing so i told leonard i go we'll
fight for the title this fight let him
strip him and we'll fight for the title
he said well he's got the option to test
for a b sample so
they can you know you got to go through
they giving this guy so many breaks
four four but why are they giving them a
break what's the deal what is your
perspective when they're giving them
these breaks
i don't have to preach it to you you
know there's politics involved
absolutely
no there's politics in boxing and
without you know getting too much into
that even though we'd like to talk a
little [ __ ] on the show
but you can't you can't because we got
you still working with you
you know and you know and they look and
they're looking at you right now there's
politics
when the show is on they're going to
watch
i've been put in a position where i
don't need anybody you know we make our
moves thank god you know we have faith
and we do things the right way we always
you know cross our t's dot our eyes and
make sure that we treat everybody
and do everything that's not always the
way that we're treated
and especially with this fight thank god
mayweather promotions enabled this vada
testing because he was dirty
and he was willing to take by dude if
that's the case what's up what's up with
logan palmer you guys don't think he was
awesome
i heard there was having training
together wow they were both in the same
camp
in puerto rico they were bought in the
same camp in puerto rico boy that
doesn't mean that logan was on anything
that's the exhibition fight this isn't
the difference but the thing is we're
pascal you're bad
we are the same we're the same age but
he's been pro a little longer he got
more mileage than me
but he looks normally you don't get
better with h right
you normally you don't get better no you
go down yeah i mean i don't care who you
are
the older you get the doubt but
i have better defense i'm a smarter
boxer than him so and he's
just the warriors take punishment you
can and possibly be
like be better with age and and you know
he got better the last
two three years mike mike you've seen
you see you've seen assault in the ring
right yeah yeah i remember that i was at
that fight
with the panama lewis hall i was at that
fight
it was 1984 duran then duran won the
title that night
he fought um what was his name um
broccoli
iron bark iran barkley won the title
that night june 16th
what's your take on steroids or anything
that has to do with people
illegally putting some things in their
heads like listen
dig right i'm not against steroids and
none of that stuff right because
everybody's using it right
but it shouldn't be used in sports where
people are physically
fighting when you risk your life yeah in
the ring it should be if you want to run
faster you want to swim faster
anything may accept physical compen
physical
confrontation so this should almost be
repercussion because i believe i forgive
you
i forget it no it's criminal criminal
it's criminal you're going to hit a man
that's attempted murder
but exactly a murder the guy i forget
his name guys billy collins risco
um louis riscoe and billy collins i was
at that fight with 18 years old he did
time
he did time yeah for the load of gloves
yeah for the load
no not even load of gloves they took
they took the padding out
and when he shook his hand he felt his
knuckles his father when he said
congratulations he felt his knuckles
through the gloves
the reason henry that i was so upset
during that fight was
i took you know badou would have knocked
pascal out and
you know you can't guarantee i'm telling
you bad you would have knocked pascal
out
he would have regained had the
redemption for his his
controversial loss he would have been
the wba champion which means the next
fight his money doubles triples
quadrupled
that part of it was five percent of what
i was angry about
95 was this piece of [ __ ] was willing to
take badu away from his family
his livelihood his lifestyle his health
and strip him all for what
for a win he's a high-priced prostitute
and that's what angered me about the
whole thing
it didn't work out that way but imagine
if it if he hurt him that's what i'm
saying
is is he was willing to do that for what
you know it's happened to me dude
actually tj dillashaw he tested positive
for our fight
you know what i'm saying how did you
feel that should not be with five
[ __ ] six different you know what i
mean five different people i mean
whatever
like i said i was expecting it for the
first fight or even before before he
fought him but that's uh in my opinion
only
that's an a-class felony it's an
attempted murder yeah
what's the difference or murder if he
dies yeah oh since he commits
suicide afterwards in 2019 it was like
four or five that's what happened
that's what happened with billy collins
he committed suicide after that fight